I would say that you need to be
concerned about violations of Rights
that you might think have nothing to do
with you because they're only affecting
those other people in particular
non-citizens people who are accused of
terrorism people whose ideas you dislike
people you dislike and so you think what
does it matter to me if their rights are
being violated what does it matter if
government is invading privacy I have
nothing to hide why should I care and
and my message is you do care I mean you
must care you have an absolutely
profound stake in the government's power
and abuse of power because once it can
exercise that power against anyone then
no one is safe and I can give you so
many examples of people including
conservative Republican you know
government officials who said why do we
need a bill of rights why do we need the
ACLU to enforce it you're not going to
be accused of anything if you're not
guilty your privacy isn't going to be
invaded unless there's some reason to
suspect you and then something happens
in their lives and they do find
themselves on the wrong side of the law
unjustifiably this happened with a
couple people for example in the Reagan
administration including his attorney
general add Meese who was being
suspected are investigated for some kind
of I can't remember what it was some
kind of I don't even want to say it was
some kind of fraud i believe and he was
ultimately never indicted but but he was
suspected and suddenly you know sort of
got the Civil Liberties religion and
said you know when you're on the other
side of the law you suddenly do
understand the importance of having
these rites so I don't want people to
have to reach that point before they
understand how how
essential it is that they never will be
in that position